Jeff Ross is here what's going on man
welcome to the show you traffic this is
crazy today right so bad okay no so it's
gonna get worse is it snowing outside
yeah how much we supposed to get by uh
this weekend they're cute ten feet uncle
yeah yeah no no we're not getting no are
we no knowing a little now though I got
it I got shows I don't want snow I don't
either
that's exciting how was the rocks thing
you were thought you were at the rock
the troops I did I was what was the rock
to trip think it the rock did like a
entertainment show you know for the
troops sure but it was in front of like
how many fifty thousand twenty-five
thousand people at Pearl Harbor Wow I
saw I've only seen photos of it like I
saw the rock and like his Elvis jumpsuit
and all that stuff did you go on I did
oh wow how was that now fully dressed as
General Patton did they enjoy they did
and and I challenged them it was created
Leonard Skinner never in my career that
I think I follow Lynyrd Skynyrd well
it's so weird that Lee and so much time
did yesterday I did whatever I wanted I
wrote a whole bit and I came out and
roast battled the rock you did yeah it
was really fun I sort of making fun of
him and he heard it and came out and
challenge me to a roast battle and leg
off it was a legit off the go we worked
it out okay how did he do it he was
hilarious he said I was he said I look
like if sweatpants were a person it was
fun and you know following Leonard
Skinner I go give it up for all the acts
you've seen so far and whatever's left
of Leonard's performing in front of an
airplane which I thought was a little
too soon that guy I hope I get it I go
I'm kidding I'm kidding
kamikazes around me at Club Pearl Harbor
today that's great the whole thing was
crazy you just have to like in your head
now are you just prepared to work pretty
much any venue audience size imaginable
because I feel like of all the comics
and maybe it's the roast thing that's
taking you there you have ended up in
front of the most I guess diverse I do
feel that I can adapt to my environment
yeah which doesn't sound like a good
thing that sort of the commune you want
your audience to come to you a little
bit but I don't know for some reason I
like
doing that different challenges yeah I
guess if it's your audience finally if
you're making fun of people want to do
stuff with people in the crowd not
everything like you want different
people around right like you don't want
to go in in different environments yeah
did a prison that was such a ballsy
special is really funny the UH when you
went into prison prosperous criminals
yeah awesome what was the other one
you're doing another place had one that
came out recently where I rose [ __ ] I
saw that oh dude it was tough
you got a there's this great video
that's really good with it tougher than
the criminal 100 times stuff why the
cops are very skeptical okay did they
laugh and they don't like me I think
they get [ __ ] on so much in the media
that they don't trust when I first got
there the only police precinct that
would let me in was the Boston cops oh
boy no unarmed persons been killed since
1991 by the Boston cops so they were
proud of that among other things are
very diverse they let me in most cities
all cities didn't and they were
skeptical of me because I'd been to a
black lives matter rally in New York and
they saw they googled me and saw a
picture of that
so they immediately thought I was in the
enemy and didn't a thing get sent around
to everybody and making sure that
everybody knew exactly before you got
there the Union circulated a letter
saying that I was cop hater oh god you
guys really are [ __ ] silly sometimes
and then and then I bomb for the first
couple days I was there and I slowly won
them over and I went back a few months
later and actually did a benefit with
the cops in the audience and got to
actually speed roast actual cops on
stage so anyway you went back more than
once on the same team in front of the
same people
yeah it really days yeah and I did ride
alongs where I would just roast the cops
in the back seat which they go well you
know they're not having it cops you know
with the environment is so funny because
it's like wow it's all the cops getting
together for like roll call and stuff
yeah before they're about to go out do
their job and like right before they go
out Jeff just has to come and make fun
of them for a little bit and they're
just stabbing they are just staring Jeff
is one I I honestly
one of the balls your comments are no
thing to do that I I couldn't do that at
that's really why I did it really was a
low point you know the the felt of the
film which you can watch on iTunes or
whatever comedy central.com you can see
but shooting it was traumatic like I
really almost quit in the middle it was
awful I couldn't get a police precinct
to agree when I finally got one to agree
they didn't want me there and and the
Union was giving me a hard time and I
eventually like earn their trust and I
learned a lot about policing and in the
end I think I felt very I don't know I
evolved on the matters of cops and and
all that stuff you had you had a differ
on opinion or I don't think I had an
accurate opinion I didn't realize how
hard it is to be a cop right and then
you know all the shootings happen in
Dallas and Baton Rouge while I was
filming so that's part of the story and
I mean there's no amount of money that
could get me to put a uniform on right
now if I was that guy
I mean it's scary after targets yeah now
more than ever a lot of affection for
cops now that I've not I've really seen
how hard it is do they show anything
yeah it surprises the bombing yes it's
me bombing really bad so they're all
going in there just in a room it's like
full of desks and stuff and it's roll
call there by the way hit pause for a
second there uh not sitting like there's
all kinds of desks in the middle of the
room set up chairs for them like to come
have a little like comedy break you know
and they just wouldn't sit down they
wouldn't smile lined up again protesting
me they're Elana grant against the wall
so they're almost like surrounding the
room yeah but they're not a part of
that's not the most comfortable comedy
environment I've ever seen know
I'll make this quick as I know most of
you are double-parked thank you for
letting me come here this is really cool
I've never performed in front of an
entire roomful of YouTube celebrities
before
this'll be so much better if you guys
just came in the middle room all right
fine
you guys also have a rich criminal
history in this town you had the Boston
Tea Party here whitey bulger was from
here Tom Brady's from here that kind of
it oh come on that one buddy let the air
out of the room huh let's be real with
whitey Bulger's name had been Blackie
Bulger they would have caught him a lot
quicker
well chuckle yeah there's obviously a
problem between the cops and the
community across the country right now
and that's what I'm here because that
really bothers me and it really bothers
me when some people say that all cops
are racist of course that's not true
most of you it just sticks to everybody
[ __ ] ha yeah thanks for coming all
right and you guys Oh Jeff you guys
didn't edit that to make that worse than
it was that was that uncomfortable I cut
it in half it was actually much worse
pounder but I just couldn't take it and
I didn't want to put the viewers through
my Intel wrong was that actual set like
when you did that how long was only 5
minutes 15 min oh God 12 to 15 minutes
there's other stuff where I start
walking around like working the room and
trying to like get to know them and
they're not having it do you it when
something like that's happened you go
okay this is now what it is like I'm
[ __ ] tanking this is now a thing
about me tanking we just have to embrace
like did this is what it's gonna be
I don't didn't realize that until weeks
later when I was editing and everyone
and you know my editor and my producer
was like let's try to use that footage
that's really fun I wouldn't even watch
it in the beginning I was like no we're
scrapping that we have to go with what
worked and it wasn't till later that I
realized that that was an essential part
of my journey yeah I had to win them
over yeah I have to see that you know
what to be honest with you the show
starts out it's called Jeff Ross roasts
cops it starts out
black lives matter rally in Washington
Square Park and people are actually
holding signs and say which side are you
on
and so by the way that's but that's why
you are at that rally right to learn yet
but you were filming for the show like
it was like you were just there
protesting cops like no like they said
my dad or I was working on this
documentary about cops and this roast of
cops and I wanted to learn I didn't want
to be just some other white dude trying
to pretend they know what's going on
when you have no idea and I got out
there and I just followed this rally for
a day and I guess there were pictures in
the paper and people mention that I was
there so when I got to the Boston cops
they were the same way which side are
you on
there's no middle area and you can't be
on both sides and I decided I was going
to be on both sides
yeah and for them if you're on both
sides that means you're on the other
side right right right right so you know
maybe maybe the smartest people on both
sides can get together and talk some do
some of this figure oh I don't know I
don't know did you did you shave your
eyebrows no they're just blonde oh yeah
she's light I couldn't tell from here
why it's just Jeff's head I know just be
an odd choice if you had what was my
joke at roast battle I look like you
look like a skinny me what did I say to
you remember but it was hurtful
were you surprised how well Rose panel
did I feel like that over like the
course of the weekend did it aired on
Comedy Central that like it became this
thing I think a lot of it was because of
social media and stuff that's where I
kind of people say it did really well on
snapchat yeah that's yeah for sure
really a press now track records and
that's why we're coming back right away
in January every Sunday in January real
gray that's awesome - when I was at one
of the judges in the New York regionals
he's awesome thank you there's some
really funny acts there there was nobody
who bombed like was one guy who buddy we
did something edgy it was very funny a
lot of really funny Roasters yeah
because I remember when that when that's
when that came on it was like I didn't
even know what it was and I just saw
people talking about it and I guess
either the finals were happening or I
was a couple episodes behind but it all
happened over the course of the weekend
right so I just put it on cable on
demand right and like I think that's
what a lot of people did
and it seemed like it really picked up
steam like really quickly we're doing it
where all the regional shows will there
every Sunday in January than the last
four days when they're in a row live
that's awesome we're taking the old
House of Blues across from the Comedy
Store on Sunset Boulevard doing that you
mentioned you wanted to do that you got
it we got it we're going to build an
arena inside there oh so cool and have
all the judges and comics from the
comedy that is so great and do it that's
so great a fun show that's a fun show
and it seems like impossible when I
realized it was live like it seems so
difficult for the comics specifically to
be able to pull that off live because
after you win like you'll have to do two
or three sets in one show which means
you'll have to have researched everybody
on the show because you don't know who's
winning is tournament-style it's 16
comics yeah so you know yeah I think
most of them know each other because
they come from different scenes we went
to four cities and the comics to do
roast battle it's almost like a group
it's like a I don't know a movement so
they've been roasting each other a lot
of them somebody write comics have done
20 battles so they have a feel for how
to do it quickly and their strategies
and counterpunching and stuff like that
it's amazing yeah that's uh it's a lot
of pressure yeah Jim's been very
supportive he visited us in Montreal
when we did it and he judged the New
York regionals and he has a lot of roast
cred so the comics the rookie Roasters
really respect what he said it was cool
thank you
well you guys used to do I mean roasting
used to be like you guys were doing it
not on television for awhile like comedy
clubs would have roast all the time
there's like we were talking when Ben
Bailey was in about the roast of Patrese
almost this guy they roast over here but
it's not until recently where like
they've been putting them all on TV who
I'm I'm I just go off the cuff
that's your things yeah you don't
research oh no I don't need to do you
have any leg like so like you're gonna
roast Jeff right I'll be like look at
that hat it's so flat with any flatted
you'd be like a pancake station oh you
got me that's actually really good right
yeah yeah when the rock hire you - good
ticket holder no better kill him no
better it's weird how like even the
debates the Trump Clinton debate felt
like a roast battle yeah absolutely
and I really felt like I could have
helped them like the spread of similar
eye contact and the way you use your
pronouns and talk to the person sort of
about the person it was that was going
to nailed that stuff that was a roast
moment when when Hillary is like I
wouldn't put you in charge and he goes
yeah because you'd be in jail and it was
like boom boom right yeah it's better
when they talk to each other it's
funnier and meaner when they address
each other you know he would say you
should be in jail and she would turn and
go Donald says like she wouldn't talk to
him yeah she she says take him yeah well
I think she was just on a defense she
thought she was gonna win so she didn't
want to take any big swings can't blame
her that you know she could have
eviscerated him I think
yeah signing the watch is that pressure
for you at the Comedy Central Roast now
because those things get so much
attention and you're going to roast
anyone because they could become
president yeah really but you wrote a
president yeah that I was at Fox on the
morning show just now and they played a
clip of me roasting Trump and I was like
this is gonna get me audited he's right
didn't eat a I can't remember what was
the story did he take it okay or I'm
alive yeah you know what he doesn't
really laugh right it's kind of mmm
smiles and I even talked to him during
the commercial and I was like dude you
know you have to at least laugh a little
bit so we have something to cut to
rights people laughing and he kind of
got it then he loosened up a little bit
yeah yeah but he wasn't because I wasn't
laughing a lot
no he just sort of winces yeah he does
he just kind of has to like he has this
weird smirking he's like okay yep
everybody laugh now let's move on to the
next thing let's move on to the next
thing Larry King is some good to some
good people there Lisa oh yeah it was a
good roast I've roasted him I've been on
his plane of like Travis plane it's
fancy schmancy hear about his plane yeah
how did you end up on his plane um I
roasted him about ten years ago for
charity at the Friars Club
I remember that roast I was like that
and and and he called me afterwards and
he offered me he made the deal with me
and I don't normally you know we don't
take our own you know negotiations but
it's Donald Trump and I really enjoyed
like talking money with him so I agreed
to this gig and he flew me and my buddy
Bruce Murtagh
down tomorrow Largo and we we did he get
always actually just a shot whoo yeah
with the stand-up shell he took very
good care of us he gave me his Cadillac
for the weekend Wow and he gave me a
great big intro oh it was free it was
just for his eyes for the members of
Mara Largo had a suit and tie on the
whole thing oh very nice
now what Celine was it was this giant
one it was hair force one that was so
you flew down on his his on the mass of
the big black under those beautiful
fancy like Renoir r--'s whatever's in
there and it was a very bumpy ride
coming home I remember I was scared I
thought maybe I was gonna die and Donald
Trump's playing this was lightning and
how was the food delish was it spacious
like ripped and lobster is it a lot of
room on the plane a lot of room very
comfortable he knows how to travel we've
got a bedroom on there yeah like a
private bedroom did then I don't know
what it looks like now now let me ask
you did you after that did you which was
a father gig right but you only got to
go to Florida on that be nice you got to
go to LA what do you mean on that plane
yeah well he lives in fly I'm in the
Mara Laura nobody said be funny was a
longer flavors like a six hour flight
instead of a two-hour flight yeah we got
enough covered in two hours yeah you did
I would tau is the only rental right now
I'll fly any of them now you don't fly
anymore
now United's stink so I'll fly I'll fly
all of them okay cuz they're Auggie so
it's not even like they all kind of got
better they're all just terrible I've
had good success with American yeah then
again you'll talk to someone else a
American stinks
this year I like your take I'm like it's
a nice plane I wish was a longer flight
yeah we fly so much yeah I get that
sometimes I'll be sitting on the train
and I got a really good seat and I'm
like I wish I'd taken along yeah you
know like wow I'm pretty comfortable I'm
always okay with a short flight yeah
fancy plane short flight even on Donald
Trump's plane because I'd be sitting
there like how many flights am I gonna
get on this thing I'd like to spend as
much time in here as possible
now did he offer you money or did you
have to say how much you want no no he
called me straight up offered me a good
amount of money
cool I don't remember a big
back-and-forth okay I think I you know
might have asked him to bring my buddy
to open because I was worried that I
wouldn't do well at that hoity-toity
crowd and I was right I did fine but
Bruce Smirnoff crushed it did he really
oh yeah as his crowd he did
better he killed Bruce's ver I haven't
seen Bruce in how many years ago sirs
this is ten years ago I haven't seen
Bruce's Bruce Smirnoff is such a funny
guy
used to have that joke about West
Hollywood when I first moved here my
neighborhood was artsy fartsy now it's
Guns II knives yeah Guzzi knives in toys
that's it everyone does a person
impression - Bruce Smirnoff Florida
what's up I gotta tell you how you
talked to Ann Coulter after the roast
but before it aired and she you remember
Adrienne she was like talking about how
most of the Roasters that were making
jokes about her were not funny and that
she crushed like she let me know that
she actually killed and then I turned
the roast on I was like I don't know if
Ann was was accurate her portrayal of
her performance to me now she seems like
she thinks she killed what people just
dicks to her cause she's Ann Coulter
people II feel I think feel like know
they know they know know and I was
especially nine like I knew she was
friends with you I've met her at the
Comedy Cellar sitting around there yeah
I knew she understands comedy sure the
producers the writers wrote her of
self-aware hilarious speech that she
would have crushed with and she
dismissed the writer she was rude to
them she didn't do anything
she put her book up on the podium and
insisted on doing stuff that she wrote
it was not self-deprecating or endearing
and whatsoever sudden she stormed off so
I don't really know either she was mad
after I didn't talk to her I she just
disappeared before we could even take a
group picture after the show way she
stormed off during the roaster after the
second it ended before we could even say
thank you or take a picture Wow
so like you know we sought our mics on
and she was at gone oh okay so I don't
know it's kind of upsetting that she
didn't have more fun because I you know
as a producer I want people that have a
blast it's a party
did the situation have fun remember I
bad the situation did an example here's
a guy who bomb just as bad maybe worse
probably learn and still thinks he
killed yes to this day is like yep we
all did well it was okay I was out of my
own
I really kept to it kept my concentrate
like you know I wish I had that blind
self-confidence that I could go up there
and fail as bad as he did and still kind
of walk out like you know I did pretty
good
yeah you know what I mean I would be a
huge star if I had that kind of
self-confident have that confidence
because I don't fail oh you haven't you
haven't experienced that you know I
understand I understand that's got to be
nice for you guys and it really makes
you relatable - yeah yeah it's just you
never fail home right after a home run
do people like to get tired of the
roasting thing because I would am at
night you Jim because he sucks your
teeth like you were about to say
something because like do people test
you like the way I would imagine it'd be
like when a fighter goes to a bar and
he's got to deal with people who think
that they're tough guys yeah like when
you're just out do people want to insult
the ocean you know for some reason then
everything that doesn't come up as much
as you would think yeah yeah like you
know what I get it it's not at a bar
when people but I'll be in the airport
when a little more it's quieter and
people be like my brother just got a
jail will you make fun of them he's
coming out of the bathroom right now do
you do it no not even for the person who
asked me to make fun of the other person
this is a defense
I dare make fun of either one of them I
just can't do that on the spot or you
know it's much I would this it's more
dismissive it's like it's what I say is
I'm walking away yeah oh yeah as opposed
to nice to meet you right it's nice no
but that make it fun for me right it's
not like you guys are having fun
together you just say something mean as
you leave right good it is it is a
license to kill and kind of fun
sometimes yeah yeah way with a lot yeah
you do right yeah I mean I just roast
people on the spot all the time but it's
just me you really do that on the spot
nealy like what would you have said to
like the rock he just did the Rock the
troops thing if the rock was like hey
Jim you want a roast battle what do you
sure all right all right so he may be
the rock now but but I'm finished with
you you're gonna be a pebble Wow
it's actually really great yep yeah
that's right run that's really good
that's really good that's really quite
spectacular off the cuff I had a go when
I said the rock you've really done well
in your career so much better than your
brothers paper and scissors all right
sound like that he has a good sense
Maria's great yeah he's great he's doing
Baywatch remake we also comes from a
world like when he was wrestling there
was a lot of kind of on-the-spot goofy
make fun of [ __ ] right that was
happening so a live microphone isn't
really gonna scare him away I think it
really gave him a good grounding for
show business yes totally humble and
cool and what to be more demeaning than
starting out in wrestling I mean he
really probably had nothing going on
yeah and to become the biggest star in
the world like that and I didn't really
care that much about the rock but then I
met him and worked with him and I watch
one of his movies on the way home and
now I'm like obsessed I love everybody
does everybody gets there with the rock
for some reason guys especially like at
some point every guy just gets to this
place where they're like oh my god I
love the rock because uyu seems like a
real lie guys the rock why shall I give
he's good-looking he's everything I'm
not right he's everything most guys
aren't and he could [ __ ] your girl in
front of you definitely but then why I
like he's a nice guy or like everybody
really is interesting and funny it's
it's hard to not like him once you like
look a little bit like I never said I
never said happy birthday texts or phone
calls I just don't do it I don't say
happy birthday on Facebook I just never
do but I tweeted the rock on his
birthday happy birthday and he tweeted
me back and it was like enough well you
know I mean the fact that he tweeted now
I'm getting a tweet on his birthday who
are you now you didn't test that we did
the right thing I don't remember what he
wrote I mean I knew I do not remember
she should be saved I did save it
somewhere I'm sorry screen grabbed it
but it was because I just gotten
verified and I figured out that the rock
isn't gonna go through all his mentions
but he will look through the verified
tab on Twitter so verified people are
talking to him you might get a tweet
back oh that's what me I was I got a
couple tweets when the show airs this
week yeah yeah
so you're Caroline's uh all weekend
tonight sold out Friday selling Sunday
just tickets for some of those shows
it's awesome my salon away my Lauren
Rose battle champ is and Christie cello
who who throws battle veterans are
opening oh really Lawrence's [ __ ]
hilarious
oh that's really funny men and then yeah
got a lot of friends and family coming
out going to be speed roast and
volunteers from the audience so if any
of you you know Apes watching
us listening to this when I come get
roasted this is your chance yeah I hope
a guy like me doesn't go up roast you
right back I'm ready for you bud
so like if he swung something at you I
don't what he said
like what if he like made fun of your
appearance how could he Jim Norton
yeah please don't buy it I loved you as
the fake baby in American sniper that's
a good one so I don't know how you cover
but how you coming back
hey look at that mustache it's sooner
than the alibi of most pedophiles very
good actually that's actually quite good
maybe you are ready for this Oh kidding
me I Rose Bell crossly
they just fun to do it's fun to do -
Rose banner yeah or just to [ __ ] on each
other's fun yeah I know it really is
enjoying its final one I should there's
no one that doesn't like it yeah I
couldn't I wouldn't be any good at it I
would just start being you know they not
even hated Octomom why I don't know she
does not like being roasted roasting
around the kitchen table
why not she probably wouldn't enjoy it
was a lot of time for a coma she still
really she still have oh yeah probably I
would hope so
she probably she tried growing real
cranky after having the equivalent of
eight punches to her [ __ ] mmm I just
found out something my headphones
why are you gay no Elvira canceled on us
why she heard I wanted to ask about Tom
Jones ripping up her [ __ ] I guess I
don't know she in the building or no I
mean assuming she's is she in the
building or not or cancel the tour no I
think it's just this show what Elvira
canceled this show why I don't know
Roland just called me and said that that
she'd cancelled him and he never got an
email he said I believe Roland Barone
literally just called we were gonna have
valve IRA in here with you that would've
been fun right
yeah but apparently Elvira do we know
what other shows is rolling here can you
talk about it yeah he's here always
right outside hang on I am let's find
out why see if rolling can talk about it
because I'd love to know why the second
day in a row we've had a guest cancel
for no reason and it's a little ironic
that it was Elvira literally when Jim
walked in today's like I don't know why
we're talking to ya I guess I said yes
wait now
reishi I just have my email I think you
shall Roland always sir she's not oh
she's not just canceling us she's had to
move all her morning to new doctor took
it something popped up where I was I
don't know I call her I'm stay like
she's a bit elderly sir yeah
Oh Myra has a busy morning Oh Jeff
please something first eyes out viral
then we have a sound like that in the
studio this is really sad oh my god oh
my god really
woman can I ask you something I guess
love when you call them elderly that's
great yes you know after what happened
with Brendan Fraser yesterday yeah when
you found out that Elvira had canceled
on the show how quickly did you start
[ __ ] your pants yes one that's like
Christmas is near Christmas bring me
something you didn't think it was good
news when you got that email no just
they updated my link with a list of
talent department and then everything is
very hitting a point at once I'm like oh
yay and then you find out oh it's all
bad news all hitting at once
yeah let's tell me yeah look at little
handle let me get in the in the in SQ
world this label is I suppose sorry jr.
Jeff Razia II thought that maybe she had
cancer cuz she you scared her off
possibility it's possible right
anything's possible
alright roasting around the room here
she looked at Roland and said oh here's
somebody who can enter the door at my
haunted house I mean we're roasting
around the room do you see are you doing
in here and she's like you know what he
has bigger tits than me about yeah I'll
bet you in tirol and she sighed rather
[ __ ] a dog I'm sorry Roland Geoff's were
like funny and stuff I'm sorry I'm sorry
the gym said thank you I apologize on
his behalf
I like rocketing dog no roast I roast
everyone fine this is Roland walked in
here she was like oh the moms pregnant
again
what'd you say Jim she'll probably walk
in a look at Sam and go ahead go on a
pitch prior hope your plane goes down
oh I am going to Pittsburgh what is that
gonna do I'm going on Saturday and this
chances are high yeah we bumpy why would
she have said that back that's just hope
for a plane crash why not
what'd she say to sick baby hey you look
like a little kid hope they find a lump
on your balls that's Nina Coralie he
just wanted to get cancer and roasting
them on fire you feel like that you know
that would be testicular cancer
they'd have to either remove a baller
you die yeah hey nice glasses I hope
you're the victim of a hate crime when
television with his classes oh he's a
nerd let's go beat up some nerd yeah
yeah I don't know if this is technically
roaster [ __ ] roasting there's a big
difference between roasting and bullying
no it's not that
you know there's not there is what's the
difference you volunteer to be roasted
right really Owens like please bully me
without Travis you want the Travis dog
to get roasted yeah all right I mean
that's on the roastmaster I see Jeff on
Travis his mom walked out on his family
when he was 21 years old but you would
have not gotten any of that context from
Rowland's roast joke witches ha ha
Travis your mom who did she want Travis
just tell Jeff who she what just tell
Travis t circumstellar Jeff Todd you out
the circumstances behind your mother
decided to abandon you and your family I
mean she did that with it with a Jewish
man and she she left she dis she
disowned the family yeah never speaking
to them again and is she Jewish now or
we don't know no she is yeah because she
stopped talking to us because she
converted yeah Chuy's can't talk to you
sounds like a great lady that's just the
best credit to our religion but I give
credit to that guy cuz what a [ __ ] that
guy must have Riyas so yeah he literally
he [ __ ] her out of her God and family
do you think you think Travis's mom do
you think Travis's mom needed stitches
the way Elvira did oh my god
shredded that [ __ ] away that no
disrespect but mr. tails wasn't it that
way
[ __ ] oh yeah but then that probably did
happen oh he wrecked it yeah I was like
oh god I haven't felt the walls been you
know he had kids surprises hasn't from
the walls hiss yeah so long especially
need the kids yeah all recollection of
those children being born
we're thrown out the window with you
when you felt the walls being she's
writing a book actually is an anonymous
book call finally getting girth that's
that's unkind it is in the memory of his
family just insulting my father sorry
yeah that's true I bet I bet I bet the
radio legend Tim 2f has a thick one no
but she does I bet he does that's rust
on you like huh what okay for the record
let's roast on you want a joke about Don
Wicklund to be thrown out there rolling
our boss yeah well you throw it out Oh
cuz he's not your boss anymore
he gets rolling now rollin found out
earlier this week that he works for the
talent department as of this week he
doesn't work for the channel anymore so
the boss of our channel is not Roland's
boss anymore
oh it's the talent department boss
that's good so what do you think about
Don I love Don though but he dresses up
like a crazy cowboy you think you're
ruthless said is that your roast joke
yeah Leon roast and rollin yeah you sure
you don't want Rowan to open for you
Caroline's I think you just did yeah I
think this is this is good do you have
anything about a Adrian Jim um like guys
you're just kind of roasting around the
room like you said yeah Adrian yeah um
hey where's your family from New Jersey
now but the rest of them I mean Cuba
I hope they drown why I'm roastin rollin
loves you as a roaster rollin has never
left this heart of your jokes in your in
gentler career yeah this is you you at
your prime you have any other role in
John who's your favorite comedian
I love for real for mmm I'm gonna guess
Ricky
I do love Ricky
ricky gervais yes you have any other
favorites I love Seinfeld
I wash him Jim Jefferies I love Jim
Jefferies I haven't I tend to be a weird
guy as to I sent him a text to I want to
ask you about a bit like you a bit like
this is just right back not me I could
talk to you yeah I mean Zach
Galifianakis
like his TV show is amusing which TV
show between two ferns and uh baskets
baskets is good yeah yeah what's wrong
with your stomach
Jim why do you roast yourself that'd be
good yeah roast your stomach but I'll
roast myself hey you [ __ ] you a dummy
[ __ ] so big I'm surprised there's any
blood left for your brain is unfair I
don't know you risks everybody else dad
kill it huh you wished everybody else
dead I'm killing myself Leah I can
murder myself oh I see
I think that's big dick stupid what are
you a person or tripod it's chilling
just nailing it yeah do we joke about if
you [ __ ] over huh um ah um think Tom
Jones is big oh yeah thank you
well vars lucky I didn't [ __ ] her Ted
grab her tits to little old lady wig
fell off nothing to do with Tom Jones
that went right up here kind of you oh
yeah I'm Jones yeah you know he's just
talking any idea Jeff was thinking you
more going in the range of your penis
being our Tom Jones teabag
yeah what makes you think British his
songs
does he sing about teabagging Elvira yes
let's get to know sings to Lila yeah no
no no no teabag Elvira when you see
feels kind of like that goes down yeah
you big Tom Jones fan left I'm just not
twice you do okay hmm it's really good
are you David
no me neither I was like are you like
hitting on him no I pick up tomorrow
Jefferson roast no women come out to
Caroline's this weekend
are you are you looking or no you like
dancing always look at you are you like
being in a relationship or I'd rather be
in a
relationship really I don't know I'm
just like the comfort of it or ATS but
I've been single awhile now I'm ready
yeah ready to meet somebody okay so I
was hoping Elvira would be how do you
usually meet with it like do dating apps
and stuff I've tried to come tried all
that and I've tried just dating whoever
shows up in wherever I am but now I'm
trying to be more adventurous and reach
for things and find people I like and
want to meet
see yeah I think that's better where do
you know how do you find them through
friends I actually called a friend who's
a lawyer in LA last night I was like I
want to meet a lawyer I want to meet
somebody really smart so you know
anybody keep me in mind
I feel like as many places as you go to
as many friends as you know you you
could be dating celebrities have you
dated celebrities I have oh how long the
longest a couple months take oh well it
was fun whoo I did fun she ended it why
um we just didn't find a gym was a
better Roessler with these English jokes
who's younger than me hmm there's fun
fling like a year ago
I don't want it did her father Billy Ray
Cyrus don't like it ray was really mad I
dare day the celebrity don't know how to
look it up you're not gonna figure it
out oh I love that I've never dated one
oh so rolling like run they good along
with her take the initiative to look it
up have you said her name you would even
google it Roland is still just singing
Tom Jones songs to her selfies yeah he's
out and doing his own Tom's giant balls
[ __ ] ripping his anus but it's got to be
difficult to to have your schedule and B
have a relationship right yeah it's
challenging yeah but I think if I met
somebody I would my schedule would adapt
no you add a single I have no one
answered to I just keep going yeah do
you bring them with you on the road like
do you want a girl who's working
full-time or a girl who has some
flexibility I would prefer somebody
who's more of a partner than a sidekick
what do you mean somebody who has her
own thing going on I can't is not just
free to like take over take take on my
life who's got I'd love to go to my
girlfriend's Christmas party or her jaw
I'd love to have somebody who's got like
a career
beefed up like a career career though
not yeah yeah just like a lawyer a
politician yeah doctor be awesome yeah
I'll never get a girl like that why do
you think that's done I'm not communi a
lawyer maybe you're to Google Louisville
yeah big and embarrassed had to be a
girl with damage yeah cuz I got to
introduce you to their friends I see
anybody who date's the comedian's
probably a little damaged but maybe this
movie that the comedian that I co-wrote
is about a younger woman who falls for
an older comedian Leslie Mann and Robert
De Niro so that you write that is you
cry right that I did I was involved with
that years ago I remember I remember
Jeff talked to me with you but that's my
five years now you read it seven years
ago yeah what seven years ago Wow so you
were working on that for that like that
that's how long ago you're working I
worked on it yeah so what's it like to
see it come to fruition because the
trailer is like out it's really getting
made is that like is it surreal at all
to realize it is I watched it with a big
smile like I couldn't believe I was
watching a home movie but also changed a
little bit mm-hmm
to see it come to life is kind of
mind-blowing plus it's all my real life
like favorite places I wrote into at the
Friars Club and the Comedy Cellar and
stuff like that and they kept all that
in yeah that's awesome that's awesome so
do you have to as the writer of it you
have to kind of write it and then give
it up yeah and like kind of I'm
hands-off and Linda takes it over and is
that tough it's a little tough you had
to watch your baby get you know raised
by somebody else
yeah because I worked a long really hard
on it was very personal how long did you
actually spend writing eight months Wow
Wow and then it's like okay we sold it
that's the goal you know it's now gone
it was closer to my my own kind of hopes
and fears in life now I've sort of
distanced from it so I can kind of watch
it with a different appreciation and
Taylor Hackford the director he was
really amazing yeah really I thought did
a great job with it yeah he's uh he
directed Rea directed officer and a
gentleman
devil's advocate Wow [ __ ] great I
guess I didn't even know that all those
movies were directed by the same dude
yeah that's pretty amazing yeah he's
marked a Helen Mirren really yeah he's a
very interesting guy
Wow his stories about everything that's
really not a bad director to realize
your script has been
paradigm lady gave me a any any
introduced made the at the AFI Film
Festival made me really happy that's
great it was cool do you actually can
like you have to give it up but like the
guy who you gave it to is still giving
you your props and everyone away I got
invited to the premiere at the Egyptian
theater and I'm just sort of you know
they're in the audience Danny DeVito and
DeNiro and I'm like god it's nice they
invited the writers you know and yeah
Here I am and suddenly two minutes into
the presentation they asked me to take a
bow with the other person that I wrote
it with and we hadn't seen each other
alone that was just a nice moment yeah
it's great I mean so often you hear
stories about writers who kind of just
like you know spend all the time writing
it and then it really is just like okay
that's in somebody else's hands you're
forgotten about you're yesterday's news
so it's the fact that they would give
you that moment is it was very very cool
buying and also the movies pretty good
and it's about us it's about comedians
and honors the art of stand-up comedy in
a cool way I think you know it's one of
those things to like creativity or
create it is in January
creativity is such a weird thing like
because but we have two people with
different creative ideas like politics
both people really are convinced they're
right right and it's so hard to see the
other person's it's there's a real art
to being able to let something go
because it's very hard to not Matt be
much so married to an idea creatively
that you become unreasonable yeah I'm
not a great collaborator cuz I get very
marriage of things yeah so I went hard
to let go it's tough for somebody who's
been a stand-up as long as you have been
and I mean same thing for you Jeff that
like being a stand-up is that place
where you have sort of it's it's all you
right so when you move into other places
where you have to share what you think
is funny or what you think is
entertaining or stuff like that it has
to be difficult because you're used to
having autonomy you are yeah and when
you have to let something go and give it
up as like okay that's all you can do is
just hand it over and see what people do
I'm you normally a great collaborator
you know because your work in writers
rooms and in television you can learn to
sort of do that right and appreciate
other people and their ideas but yeah
Jim's right it's tough to let it go but
I might if you write something /
yeah if you're sitting around the
writers I'm gonna sitcom and it's
animated yeah you know you're not just
kind of write Ares to the ideas but with
like the comedian movie I mean a lot of
stuff and that movie happen to me so I
watch it and it's hard to it's sometimes
it's hard to let it go
well Jeff like Jeff this is like it's
really hard for me like even if I'm
writing row stuff and you have somebody
helping you right I'm very bad at
sitting in a room and going that that
now though I I can't do it I get ashamed
and humiliated my guys who can kiss at
rejection your your rejection oh I just
hate it I'm like just email to me write
it down and I'll look at it I can yeah
yeah better edit quietly just reading it
I don't like to edit verbally like that
I hate it it makes me so uncomfortable I
can so you can do it I've seen Jeff do
it and he'll just throw out joke ideas
and some are funny and sometimes it's
not and he's okay either way it's that's
part of the job you just keep swinging
if you're in that in a brainstorming
session sometimes a bad idea will spark
a good idea or you'll realize why it's a
bad idea and you go the other way and
you know if you're if you're confident
in your comedy I learned that from
working like writing for Billy Crystal
on the Oscars and Chris Rock and Jamie
Foxx and people like that on award shows
that you just got to keep swinging and
and and not be too sensitive about
yourself well you're not like the weird
thing is like when in those moments back
and forth I would you're not a you're
not worried that if someone says now
that's a terrible joke it's a rejection
of you as a performer since day one
right like I take it as a rejection of
like I don't know the jury's in you've
been a fraud since 99 right so
unreasonable this stupid this joke is
your entire career yes you gotta know I
gotta know at a certain point that it's
not just a joke in that moment and and
you're just trying to make them laugh or
whatever my first sitcom job was writing
for The Drew Carey Show and I remember
the there's all these like I was working
like as a consultant like one day a week
and all these writers were there
full-time and they all went home to
their families and their beautiful
houses they were making a good living
and I was going back to a Best Western
so I just wanted to stay all night and
wanted to get home and I was constantly
trying to make them laugh
in fact they didn't want they wanted to
make America laugh right shoe carry was
the number-one sitcom so they had no top
patience for my life that's when I
learned oh you know what enough like
trying to like you know be the class
clown let's just get the work done it
right you know an outbreak for this for
the scene
yeah and once you roll up your sleeves
and realize it's a job but it's work
you can get pretty good at it well
listen you got a busy January
you got the comedian that's going to be
out that people are going to be able to
see this thing that you worked on a long
time ago
you've got second season of roasts
battle which is premiering on January
26th yeah he's a good sport about the
the roasting thing like a lot of people
would be like well this is what I do on
TV but my stand-ups different in ba ba
ba it's like no like you get that people
want to get roasted by the guy who's on
all the roasts so you do it it's fun
yeah I like it started even like as the
audiences became more comedic ly savvy
and a lot of the morning radio and and
just stand up and over the years I think
people start to understand stand-up
better I go well let me make my show
interactive I like bringing people up
people are starting to heckle with
videotape every comic so don't like [ __ ]
that just all right come up here right
right like you're getting yelled at you
got balls raise your hand you wanna come
up here you're not now now you're part
of the show on my terms
I love it and of course Norton's going
to be at the Tarrytown Music Hall Terry
time music all New Year's Eve and yeah
he's very happy to be done with the tour
yeah it's gonna be good and thanks Jeff
so Thank You Man good seeing you a cool
new show fellas thanks man Ben first fun